Today we're going to talk
about Wallace versus Smith.
A case decided by the New Mexico Court
of Appeals in 2001 like cases we've been
discussing recently.
Wallace versus Smith involves
the enforceability of
contract claims as well as
the viability of tort claims
in light of public policy.
This case is an appeal from a dismissal
of the complaint for failure to state a
claim and so on.
Appeal.
The court assumes the allegations of the
complaint are true for the purposes of
determining whether the complaint
states a viable claim for relief.
The plaintiff,
Peter Wallace,
alleges that he and defendant Kelly Race
Smith were a couple engaged in a sexual
relationship.
Wallace made it clear that he did not
want to father a child and the two talked
about possible methods of contraception.
They agreed that Smith would use birth
control pills and that their sexual
intimacy would cease if Smith
stopped using birth control.
Wallace did not himself use
any form of contraception.
At some point, Smith decided
to stop taking birth control,
but she did not tell Wallace.
She had stopped and the two
continued their relationship.
Smith became pregnant and
gave birth to a daughter.
New Mexico law required Wallace to pay
child support for the first 18 years of
his child's life, while a sued for
compensatory and punitive damages.
Arguing that because of the child support
obligations created by Smith's failure
to tell him she had ceased
taking birth control pills,
he had suffered a substantial economic
injury. The trial court, however,
determine that public policy prohibited
Wallace from bringing those claims.
The court of appeals agreed.
Recall our previous discussions about the
factors that weigh in favor of finding
that a particular public policy exists.
One of the primary factors is what the
legislature has said on the subject.
The court emphasize that our legislature
has spoken to the public policy that
governs the economic consequences of
sexual relationships that produce children
and that policy is reflected in
New Mexico child support laws.
New Mexico had adopted
the uniform parentage act,
which quote imposes a form of strict
liability for child support without regard
to which parent bears the
greater responsibility for
the child's being unquote.
That in turn reflected a strong public
policy that makes paramount the interest
of the child genera generally in a,
it was in the child's best interest
to receive financial support from both
parents by seeking to recover for the
very financial loss caused him by the
statutory obligation to pay child support.
Wallace was attempting to circumvent is
support obligations and shift financial
responsibility for their
child entirely on to Smith.
The court of appeals determined this
contravene the state's public policy and
noted that tar knowledge,
no jurisdiction recognizes contraceptive
fraud or breach of promise to practice
birth control as a ground for Justin
and natural parent's obligation to pay
child support.
The court denied Wallaces
fraud claims noting quote,
not all misrepresentations are
actionable unquote judge Allred's.
Concurrence delved more deeply into the
misrepresentation argument explaining if
we recognize a claim based on
intentional misrepresentation,
we have started down the road toward
establishing standards of conduct and
reproductive relationships.
One of the most important and private
forms of interpersonal relations,
candor and reproductive matters should
be left to the ethics of the participants
unquote, whether expressed as
a contract or a tort claim.
The court of appeals was clear that
the economic injury caused by unwanted
fatherhood was not compensable.
Yeah.
The opinions recital of facts suggest
that Smith initially used birth control as
agreed and only later changed her mind.
But what if the facts were just did
slightly imagine that Smith never intended
to use birth control at all when
she promised Wallace that you would,
what kind of claim would
that possibly suggest?
Well,
it sounds like promissory fraud.
Could Wallace pursue a promissory
fraud claim? In theory,
the arguments for promissory fraud
look strong, especially a Smith,
we're financially secure and could
provide for her child the loan,
but courts have not
entertained such claims and the
contraceptive fraud context,
perhaps the reality of intimate
relationships and the often imperfect
understanding those in such relationships
have of one another's intentions.
Make that a good thing
to mind. Mind, however,
the court goes too far and is in
establishing an immutable rule against
liability.
The court evidentiary concern could
be handled by only enforcing written
agreements of the kind that we've seen
in the frozen embryo cases and the
court's concern about child support
could be handled by keeping the plaintiff
contingently on the hook for support
if the defendant failed to have enough
resources to pay for the child.
Imagine now that Wallace and Smith had
the same agreement to only have sex when
contraceptives were used,
but that that it was Wallace who
would use a contraceptive if Wallace
intentionally ceased doing so and Smith
became pregnant when she has a better
claim for damages.
And then did in this case,
notice that the court's opinion focuses
on the fact that Wallace sought recovery
purely for economic injury.
Indeed,
judge Alridge expressly declined to
address whether tortuously inflicted
physical harm to a sex
partner would be foreclosed.
In a similar case,
the fact that pregnancy would cause Smith
to cover physical trauma in addition
to economic harm might make
such a claim more plausible.
Would a broken promise by a man to use
contraceptive be more enforceable than a
broken promise by a woman?
Would promises not to use contraceptives?
Be More enforceable under
contractor toward fraudulently
inducing consent to sex
as a kind of assault,
isn't it?
Now let's move away from the procreation
promises and consider instead of very
different hypothetical that raises some
of the public policy concerns we've been
discussing.
Imagine that a bunch of professors are
at a dinner together before the start of
the fall semester.
Professor a mentions that he's planning
to sell his used car once the incoming
students arrive on campus.
Professor B who has just arrived for the
year carless as a visiting lecture says
she herself might want to buy the car
and wants to know if she can have a
mechanic examine it before purchasing it.
Professor a agrees but only on the
condition that professor B not disclose
anything about what the mechanic fines.
Professor B agrees after the
mechanic looks at the car.
Professor B calls professor a to say she
does not want the car and begins to say
that the mechanic found a problem with it.
Professor a though cuts in says,
don't tell me professor B response,
but it's a safety problem and
professor a repeats. Don't tell me.
Professor a then sells the car
to an incoming graduate student.
A does not disclose his agreement
with Professor B and uh,
professor aid does not disclose that.
B had said there was a safety problem
with the car later the graduate students
suffers injuries in a car accident
caused by that very safety problem.
Should a should professor a
face any liability for the
students accident and did
professor be breached and enforceable
promise when professor B told professor
aid there was a safety
problem with the car.
As you probably sense
enforcing an agreement to
remain silent in the face of a
serious safety issue like
the one described in this
hypothetical would almost
surely be against public policy.
Though professor be breached,
the agreement to remain silent,
professor B would not be liable because
of the agreement would be found to be
against public policy.
And once professor a learned
via the breach that there
was a safety problem with
the car.
Professor a had a duty to disclose this
to the student professor A's failure to
do so would be a tort
and possibly criminal.
But are there potentially
negative consequences to
not enforcing this agreement
to remain silent?
If professor a knew that the agreement
with professor a two with Professor B to
remain silent,
we're not enforceable,
professor a probably wouldn't have let
professor be inspect the car at all.
This wouldn't give the student seeking
to buy the car any new safety information
because pref professor a would
have remained willfully ignorant.
One possible alternative would be to make
professor be liable for small damages
for contractual breach if she
disclosed adverse safety information.
But making professor be liable
for large damages in tort.
If she failed to disclose safety
information and a subsequent purchaser was
hurt,
the damages for breach would likely be
much smaller because they would only
represent the a reduction in price of
the car that would now have to be fixed,
that professor A's of the world would
still allow inspection and the professor
B's might be willing to enter this kind
of agreement because of the possibility
that no adverse safety information
would been terrilizer during such an
inspection.
Perversely,
by enforcing the silent promise,
the law might produce
more safety information.
So what have we learned from Wallace
and this agreement to remain silent?
Hypothetical from Wallace,
we know that courts generally will not
recognize contraception fall contra
contraception,
fraud claims based on economic injury
caused by an obligation to pay child
support and know the reasoning was
based on the best interest of the child.
The case echoes some of the concerns about
interfering with private and intimate
relationships.
We've touched on in previous cases from
the hypothetical about remaining silent.
We saw another example of an agreement
in a context that would almost
universally be considered unenforceable,
but we also considered the potential
negative implications of a policy against
enforcement and a possible
alternative policy.